you know it's not okay using someone's
mental health struggles as a weapon when
you attack them for you know basically
you don't have an argument against some
so you just say they're nuts well of
course that's what they're doing with
Kanye West his political views not all
that important but he just hurled
insults at him to try to demonize him
it's simply disgusting this was an
embarrassment
Kanye's mother is rolling over in her
grave not only was this a crazy
conversation for this White House this
is the kind of conversation that would
typically be held between people wearing
Hospital bracelets no no if he's open to
help but I just feel like this is a
public cry for help and he's not getting
anything out there was a ranting lunatic
in the Oval Office today Kanye back away
from the cameras go get some help and
then come back and make your case can't
help dr. lemon why are you stinking
sizing people who battle mental health
issues how dare you try to minimize what
Kanye is saying because he's open about
some of the mental health issues he said
I think you owe Kanye and everyone else
dealing with these struggles and apology
and you need to do better
Donna Lum is actually a good guy he
knows better joining me now is Patrick
Corrigan psychology professor and author
of the book the stigma effect all right
professor
now how Dilla tereus is it for anyone in
the media left-wing right-wing to
exploit another person's medical history
as was done just over the past 24 hours
regarding Kanye West reducing some of
these conversation to illegitimate by
saying they're mentally ill is in the
same category as a stigma related to
racism sexism homophobia it's saying
that your message doesn't count because
once upon a time you had experience with
bipolar disorder or other illness the
stigma mental illness is not trivial
people labeled with mental illness
aren't able to get jobs live
independently get good healthcare and
it's all because messages like this
perpetuate them is being different worse
than we
and professor it seems like it would
deter people from getting counseling
let's say they lost a parent went
through a difficult time if they know
later on they're gonna be described as
one of those people who got help and I
someone who knows a lot of people over
the years who have gone through
especially with like death of children
does the parent gone through incredibly
difficult periods of time we want to
encourage people to be able to talk to
others to get help and to me in this
case it's the it's it's mostly liberal
sadly in this situation who are
demonizing someone just because I guess
they're in the Oval Office with Trump
and throwing in the crazytown deal as a
way to demonize him and dismiss him
anytime you throw in the word crazy
whether comes from the left or comes to
the right it undermines the
opportunities of people who struggle
with mental illness and by the way
that's a lot of people um Epidemiology
suggests could be one out of five people
have a serious mental illness
the stigma fundamentally comes from the
label I'm seeing somebody come out of a
psychiatrist office and they know they
must be nutz or coming out of the
counselor's office and they must be
crazy and so they're going to avoid
those kind of places so they don't get
those kind of labels and they're not
going to get the kind of treatment you
were just talking about that we know we
really will work professor thank you so
much for your insight